- He could not allow
himself to be the first
American president to have lost a war.
And so, so he could know
that this isn't going well.
He could know that these
generals who've given him a certain
optimistic read have given him
optimistic reads before that aren't true.
And he could have the political instincts
to understand how this
war is playing negatively
in the country but he was trapped.
He was trapped in that spot
that he didn't want in history
as the first president
who would lose a war.
So his continued commitment to it was
always not so much a commitment to win,
but a commitment to punish,
through the art of war,
to punish the North Vietnamese
to the point where they
would negotiate some kind
of thing that Lyndon Johnson could say was
not defeat for the United States.
And then he ended up
being followed by Nixon
who was guided by the same principle,
couldn't be the first
president to lose a war.